we've got a triangle here where we know
two of the angles and one of the sides
and what I claim is that I can figure
out everything else about this triangle
just with this information you give me
two angles and a side and I can figure
out what the other two sides are going
to be and I can of course figure out the
third angle so let's let's try to figure
that out and the way that we're going to
do it we're going to use something
called the law of sines and in a future
video I will prove the law of sines but
here I am just going to show you how we
can actually apply it and it's a fairly
straightforward idea the law of sines
just tells us that the ratio between
açaí the sine of an angle and the side
opposite to it is going to be constant
for any of the angles in a triangle so
for example for this triangle right over
here this is a 30-degree angle this is a
45 degree angle they have to add up to
180 so so this right over here has to be
a let's see so it's going to be 180
minus 45 minus 30 that's 180 minus 75 so
this is going to equal 105 degree angle
right over here 105 degree angle and so
applying the law of sines here and
actually let me label the different
sides let's call this side right over
here let's call this side right over
here side a or has length a and let's
call this side right over here let's say
this side right over here has length
length B so the law of sines tells us
that the ratio between the sine of an
angle and it the opposite side is going
to be constant through this triangle so
it tells us that sine of this angle sine
of 30 degrees over the length of the
side opposite is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to sine of 105 degrees
sine of 105 degrees over the length of
the side opposite to it which is going
to be equal to which is going to be
equal to sine of 45 degrees sine of 45
degrees equal to the length of the side
opposite so sine of 45 degrees over B
and so if we wanted to figure out a we
could solve this
equation right over here and if we
wanted to solve for B we could just set
this equal to that right over there so
let's solve each of these so what is the
sine of 30 degrees well you just might
remember it from your unit circles or
from even 30-60-90 triangles so that's
one-half and if you don't remember it
you can use a calculator to verify that
I already verify that this is in degree
mode so it's point five so this is going
to be equal to one-half over two so the
another way of thinking about it that's
going to be equal to one fourth this
piece is equal to one fourth is equal to
a sine of a hot or is equal to sine of
105 degrees over a so let me write this
this is equal to sine of 105 degrees
over a and actually we could also say
since we could actually kind of do both
at the same time that this is equal to
that that 1/4 is equal to is equal to
sine of 45 degrees over be actually sine
of 45 degrees is another one of those
that it's easy to jump out of kind of
your unit circle you might remember it's
square root of 2 over 2 so let's just
write that that's square root of 2
square root of 2 over 2 and you could
use a calculator but you'll get some
decimal value right over there but in
either case in either of these equations
let's solve for a and then let's solve
for B so one thing we could do is we
could take the reciprocal of both sides
of this equation the reciprocal of 1/4
is 4 and the reciprocal of this
right-hand side is a over the sine of
105 degrees and now to solve for a we
could just multiply both sides times the
sine of 105 degrees so we get 4 times
the sine 4 times the sine of 105 degrees
is equal to a so let's get our
calculator out so 4 times the sine of
105 gives us let's see it's
approximately equal to let's say let's
just round to the nearest hundreds 3.86
so a is approximately equal to three
point eight six so approximately three
point eight six which looks about right
if this is two and
I made my angles appropriately that
looks like about 3.86 let's figure out
what B is we could once again take the
reciprocal of both sides of this and we
get four is equal to B over square root
of two over two we can multiply both
sides times square root of two over two
and we would get B is equal to four four
times the square root of two over two
square root of two over two or we can
think of it B is four times the sine of
45 degrees but let's think let's figure
out what that is so if we want an actual
numerical value we could just write this
as two square roots of two but let's
actually figure out what that is two
square roots of two is equal to two
point most is eight three so B B is
approximately equal to two point eight
three so I'm going to be clear this 4
divided by two is two square roots of
two which is two point eight which is
approximately equal to approximately
equal to two point eight three if we
round to the nearest hundreds two point
eight three which also seems pretty
reasonable here so the key the key of
the law of cosines is if you have let's
say you have two angles and a side you
are able to figure out everything else
about it or if you actually had two if
you had two sides and an angle you also
would be able to figure out everything
else about the triangle